de novembre 1986 aucune loi électorale
ni disposition ne dispense d'avoir des
électeurs dites vous bien que même une
répartition et une délimitation des
circonscriptions vicieuse ne
constitueront pas un manque ablement un
rempart face à la montée des
mécontentements des frustrations et des
souffrances de nos compatriotes quand
bien même vous penseriez que les plus
dignes les plus démunis assailli par
tant de difficultés finirait par se
détourner des urnes voilà pourquoi nous
rejetons sans hésitation cet article
unique parce qu'il est unique
la parole est un monsieur jean louis
masson
voilà oui chers collègues je reviens sur
la moselle et j'entends dire quelqu'un
là encore la moselle
ce n'est pas de la faute des mosellans
si la moselle et le département de
france qui a été le plus charcuter une
manière la plus injuste et la plus
regrettable alors la moselle fait
effectivement partie de ses 21
départements où la commission de
contrôle du redécoupage électoral et le
conseil d'état ont rendu un avis négatif
et parmi ces 21 c'est certainement le
cas le plus emblématique
je leur dirai encore à l'occasion de mon
amendement ou peut-être d'un autre
amendement qui concerne je les ai vus la
moselle qu'elles sont l'origine des
problèmes mais tout à l'heure j'ai
évoqué le secteur de thionville qui
n'est pas épargnée non plus par les
coups de ciseaux intempestifs deux du
gouvernement j'ai évoqué le cas de
thionville pour dire que le fait que
cette circonscription de thionville est
correspondait quasiment à
l'arrondissement et tout le monde était
d'accord pour la faire correspondre à
l'arrondissement pour des raisons
démographiques que à la limite on peut
comprendre le gouvernement a considéré
qu'il fallait lui enlever un peu
d'habitants fait même beaucoup
d'habitants puisque c'est la plus grande
de moselle alors à partir du moment où
on lui a enlevé quelque chose encore
fallait-il enlever ce qu'il fallait pour
la rapprocher le plus possible de la
moyenne départementale
eh bien on a fait exactement le
contraire car on pouvait enlever le
canton tiers qu'on pouvait enlever le
canton de cattenom on pouvait enlever la
moitié du canton thionville ouest qui en
deux parties on pouvait également enlevé
l'une ou l'autre des deux parties du
canton de yutz et notamment la commune
de terville qui est l'une des deux
parties du canton du luc et bien qu est
ce qu on a fait ce qu'on a fait c'est
qu'on a enlevé très curieusement la plus
petite des partis qu'on pouvait enlever
en l'espèce la commune d'ollioules 6000
habitants ce qui fait que la
circonscription de thionville est reste
la plus peuplée
si on avait été honnête et que vraiment
on voulait rétablir un équilibre
démographique on aurait enlevé un canton
entier ce qui permettait de se
rapprocher quasi parfaitement de la
moyenne départementale où on aurait
enlevé la grosse moitié du canton duty
ou le canton 2 de thionville ouest et à
ce moment là on était tout près de la
moyenne départementale
et bien non on a enlevé terville pour la
raison que j'ai dit tout à l'heure
tout simplement parce que l'air de
terville envie de se présenter aux
élections et que pour l'empêcher de se
présenter aux élections
eh bien on prend sa commune pour la
mettre dans une circonscription où il a
strictement rien à voir
alors là aussi monsieur le ministre
c'est un peu gros à la limite on aurait
pu comprendre que pour des raisons
démographiques vous puissiez enlever une
partie donc de l'arrondissement de
thionville est ce qu'il fallait un peu
le réduire mais par pitié monsieur le
ministre
à ce moment là il fallait faire ce qu'il
fallait pour se rapprocher de la moyenne
départementale est pas une nouvelle
magouille supplémentaires qui se rajoute
à l'énorme magouilles que vous avez déjà
fait sur la région messine dieu
à vis de la cause
l'amendement numéro 24
c'est madame mathon poinat il est déjà
défendu avis de la commission
un des favoris puisqu'ils visent à
refuser l'article unique alors bien
entendu nous sommes défavorables à vis
du gouvernement favorable ni défavorable
donc deux avis défavorables
j'ai été saisi d'une demande de scrutin
public par le groupe ump
il va être procédé au scrutin public
dans les conditions fixées par l'article
56 du règlement ceux qui souhaitent
voter pour remettront aux secrétaires un
bulletin blanc
ceux qui souhaitent voter contre métro
un bulletin bleu ceux qui souhaitent
s'abstenir remettront un bulletin rouge
le scrutin sera ouvert dans quelques
instants
g
m
donc c'est un et claude j'invite
mesdames et messieurs les secrétaires a
procédé au dépouillement du scrutin
honnêtement ça va pas
non
nous sommes ça c'est un problème
mais
vous
dans l'eure
allo
par le résultat
pourquoi ces réponses
attendant un résultat légèrement
je
fondamente été tués
on progresse
non
aujourd'hui
on
non
et
frans
mes chers collègues je propose une
suspension de dix minutes alors
résultats du scrutin numéro 107 nombre
de votants 324 nombre de suffrages
exprimés
323 majorité absolue des suffrages
162 pour l'adoption 167 contre 156
messieurs à vous monsieur abou monsieur
le président à bout et ensuite monsieur
le ministre
comme je voulais fait savoir avant même
la publication du résultat de ce scrutin
une erreur humaine s'est produite au
moment du vote
et au lieu de prendre le paquet d'aidés
carte de notre groupe que j'avais
préparé personnellement est posée à ma
place
le sénateur de notre groupe
arrivé au moment du vote a cru devoir
tirer un paquet entier dans mon tiroir
pensant que nous votions pour le texte
sur l'article et non pas sur un
amendement et c'est une grande
différence car nous n'étions pas au
stade de voter sur l'article mais sur un
amendement de là est venue la confusion
et je regrette qu alors qu'il s'en est
rendu compte au moment où il avait fait
qu'ils aillent vous la fait observer à
vous même vous ayez tout de même ce qui
n'est pas conforme à notre tradition
procédé est est ce que vous pouvez
est-ce que vous pouvez vous taire
mais attendez je vais chers collègues
mes chers collègues jean suggère je
suggère que nous nous excusions europe
de l'innocence soyeux calme non monsieur
le président la seule chose si je te
permettent de terminer notre collègue ne
m'a pas saisi personnellement je
rétablis les choses alors vous
poursuivez vous pouvez simplement il a
indiqué il me semble qu'il m'a dit avoir
informé la présidence qu'il avait
effectivement commis cette erreur et
donc je regrette que l'on n'ait laissé
aller jusqu'au bout au ce vote alors que
la tradition de notre assemblée est
toujours de procéder à la correction des
erreurs matérielles
même en cours de vote et d'annuler les
votes
je les dis que c'était la faute de
personne je dis simplement qu'il vienne
jeudi qu'il y a une tradition
républicaine entre nous je pense que
j'ai toujours respecté toutes les
erreurs des autres
je m'aperçois que vous êtes très
intolérants et je regrette ce n'est pas
l'image de notre assemblée
je pense que nous je ne crois pas que
nous sommes aujourd'hui au sénat quand
je vois de tels comportements
monsieur le ministre la madame la
présidente remercie en application de
l'article 43 lignes à 4 du règlement du
sénat
je demande une seconde délibération en
vol avant le vote sur l'ensemble du
projet de loi s'agit donc de rétablir
l'article unique du texte ainsi rédigé
je reprécise l'ordonance 2039 935 du 29
juillet 2009 portant répartition des
sièges et délimitation des
circonscriptions pour l'élection des
députés prise en application de la loi
2000 39,39 du 13 janvier 2009 relative à
la commission prévue l'article 25 de la
constitution et à l'élection des députés
et autorisant le gouvernement à fixer le
nombre total est à délimiter les
circonscriptions des députés élus par
les français établis hors de france est
à mettre à jour la répartition des
sièges de députés élus dans les
départements et des collectivités
d'outre-mer ainsi que la délimitation
des circonscriptions législatives et
ratifié ferme les guillemets merci
madame la présidente
istres je vais d'abord demandé l'avis de
la commission sur la demande de seconde
b ration ensuite monsieur frimas je
voudrais la parole oui madame la
présidente il est évident que compte
tenu de vote émis la deuxième
délibération de paraît tout à fait
nécessaire oui elle paraît nécessaire
franchement c'est pas la peine de la
deuxième délibération me paraît
nécessaire et je dois donc la commission
donne un avis favorable
alors je précise que la demande du goût
la demande du gouvernement d'une seconde
délibération ne fait l'objet d'aucune
explication de vote
en revanche il peut y avoir une prise de
parole contre monsieur frimas je
souhaite faire les choses dans l'ordre
nous y viendrons monsieur masson allez-y
monsieur film
merci madame a pris au jeu même fondée
sur le même article que nos ministres et
des articles 43 alinéa 4 essais tati 43
alinéa 4 dit avant le vote de l'ensemble
du texte
or que s'est il passé il y ait eu un
vote
ce vote a été un vote supprimant
l'article
donc au moment où nous discutons puisque
le vote a été proclamée il n'ya plus
d'articles il n'y a donc plus de ce
texte de loi nous ne pouvons donc pas en
conséquence nous trouver avant le vote
sur l'ensemble du texte puisqu'il n'y a
plus de texte
nous avons déjà connu cette situation
avec un débat sur l'éducation nationale
avec je crois c'était un article 6 à
l'époque et le débat s'arrête il n'y a
plus de texte alors
je comprends tout ce qu'on veut
comprendre mais si on invoque le
règlement il faut l'invoquer dans sa
logique
or qu'il y ait des deuxièmes
délibérations à la demande du
gouvernement acceptable au sénat nous en
avons nous en connaissons pour des
raisons que nous connaissons tous au
moment de chaque loi de finances et la
deuxième délibération est déjà quelque
chose qui est arrivé mais n arrivent
toujours dans un texte qui a été amendé
et qui permet au gouvernement de revenir
sur certains amendements qu'ils
n'acceptent pas là nous sommes dans un
cas et nous n'y sommes pour rien nous
constatons cette situation nous
constatons que au moment où nous parlons
il n'y a plus de texte puisque le tel
amendement a supprimé et quand on
préside la séance c'est une situation
que je peux imaginer quand on préside la
séance et que un amendement supprime le
texte
eh bien il n'y a pas de vote sur
l'article l'article est supprimée parce
que l'amendement de suppression a été
votée
et quand le texte de loi se compose d'un
seul article
eh bien il n'y a plus de texte de loi
donc là nous sommes sur un point de
procédure très clair sur lequel le
problème n'est pas de savoir s'il est
nécessaire nécessaires pour qu'ils
nécessaire pourquoi nécessaire pour vous
pour voter le projet de loi
effectivement il faudra que le parlement
délibère mais il ya une règle le sénat
n'a pas adopté
il n'y a plus de texte et donc comme
nous n'avons pas voté assemblée et sénat
dans les mêmes termes la scl éléments
acceptable c'est que le texte repart à
l'assemblée nationale et nous reviennent
nous aurons ainsi respecter le principe
de la navette dans le parlementarisme
voilà madame la présidente ce que je
peux essayer n'étant pas juriste
d'articuler sur cet élément
sachant que vous savez comme moi que le
conseil constitutionnel a jugé du fonds
où il a aussi à juger de la forme dans
laquelle une loi est adoptée et si un
projet de loi est adopté en
contradiction avec le règlement de
l'assemblée
eh bien il n'est pas adoptée dans les
formes
en conséquence je pense qu'il ne faut
pas que le gouvernement n'a pas le droit
sauf un compte revenir au règlement
intérieur du sénat n'a pas le droit de
demander une seconde délibération
je vous remercie de du calme dans lequel
vous m'avez écouté dont je souhaite
qu'il perdure monsieur fisher monsieur
le président fischer
oui madame la présidente
bon nous sommes très attentifs à cette
discussion puisque l'amendement de
suppression a été déposé par mon groupe
a été défendu par josiane mathon-poinat
donc le vote a eu lieu et
l'interprétation que nous en avons est
très claire il n'y a plus de texte est
d'ailleurs le la l'article 43 ans son
quatrième paragraphe dit bien avant le
vote sur l'ensemble d'un texte tout ou
partie de celui ci peut être renvoyée
sur décision du sénat à la commission
mais là le texte a été supprimé donc
nous avons cette interprétation ou
aujourd'hui bien le texte doit être
envoyé à l'assemblée nationale et nous
en discuterons dans une future séance
c'est clair c'est clair monsieur masson
le président que j'aimerais tout d'abord
dans le cadre de l'application du
règlement je réclame tout d'abord
regretté que l'on ait mis plus d'une
demi-heure pour publier les résultats du
scrutin
un résultat de ce scrutin se se mesure
au faso se dépouillant cinq minutes
d'habitude
là on a mis plus d'une demi heure ça
jette une suspicion grad sur toutes les
opérations qui sont conduites
actuellement et donc c'est une raison
supplémentaire pour moi pour soutenir
tout à fait les raisonnements et les
analyse juridique sur l'application des
règlements qui sont formulées par nos
collègues du groupe socialiste et du
groupe communiste et je trouve qu'il
serait tout à fait indécent qu'on ignore
finalement cette réalité mais le scrutin
a été annoncé il est il est clair en
fait il ya deux interprétations qui ont
été émises ici celle du président frimas
et du président fischer qui considère
que l'adoption d'un amendement de
suppression supprime le texte il ya
l'argument du président à bout qui
expliquant le l'erreur d'un de purement
matérielle dans nos collègues dit ce
n'était pas un vote sur l'ensemble du
texte mais sur un amendement
ce sont donc deux deux versions de la
situation je ne me sens pas habilité à
trancher entre ces deux versions une des
façons de le faire c'est de passer au
vote
oui allez-y monsieur todeschini
merci maintenant la présidente moi
j'aurais revenir sur les propos de
monsieur abou qui a regretté consultant
télé c'est qu'on ait proclamé le
résultat
moi je crois d'abord que c'est ce n'est
pas très élégant vis-à-vis de la
présidence qui est dans une situation
qui est dans une situation très
difficile mais je le dis calmement
dessus à bout en revanche je ne peux pas
laisser passer le fait d'assumer que
vous nous fassiez assumer à nous cette
responsabilité l'ump l'ump qui veut
faire passer aux canaux un découpage des
circonscriptions que j'ai appelé
charcutage des interventions mais j'y
reviens pas de doit assumer sa
responsabilité
on peut pas nous reprocher à nous d'être
absent de l'hémicycle quand quelqu'un
prend la parole et tout simplement les
bancs de l'ump sont vides
si les ump avait été là si les ump avait
été là il y aurait pas eu de soucis mais
on a bien vu ce soir que dans chaque
vote sur chaque demande de vote
on a eu droit à un scrutin public
demandé par l'ump car ils n'étaient pas
assez nombreux en séance
vous permettez quand même on peut pas
laisser faire n'importe quoi on n'est
pas dans une régie un régime bananier
alors erreur certainement il y a eu mais
si si un électeur vous dites on vous
avez perdu une commune de 3 voix une
commune et trois mois qu'il s'est trompé
au fond de l'urne vous n'allez pas
chercher de bulletins et ben
recommençant le système et puis on vous
reparlera de la moselle vous reparlera
des étrangers on vous parlera des débuts
découpage électoral
mais ce soir le vote est acquis
non mais attendez mes chers collègues le
vote est acquis c'est clair le problème
c'est d'interpréter s'il s'agit d'un
vote sur l'ensemble du texte ou s'il
s'agit d'un vote sur un amendement
moi je ne me sens pas habilité à
trancher
donc c'est au sénat de je dirais de
prendre sa responsabilité
tous les éléments sont connus monsieur
le président bayle oui madame la
présidente je crois que ce moment est
important il est important pour le sénat
lui-même
je pense que nous avons vraiment à être
soucieux de l'image que nous pouvons
donner l'image que nous donnons ce soir
est quand même une image comment
dirais-je d'improvisation et je pense
que ce qu'il faut privilégier c'est
véritablement la dignité de cette
assemblée la dignité de cette assemblée
signifie que lorsque nous sommes passés
au vote
et quelles qu'en soient les
circonstances et je comprends l'état
d'esprit tout à l'heure du président à
bout mais quelles qu'en soient les
circonstances il faut respecter d'abord
ce que disent les urnes et ensuite notre
règlement dans l'état actuel des choses
et au stade où nous en sommes arrivés
avec vous l'imaginez la publicité qui
est donné à cet incident revenir en
arrière signifierait une certaine
manière
comment dire décrédibiliser totalement
le sénat nous ne le souhaitons pas nous
ne souhaitons pas que nos actes et en
particulier celui qui est le plus
solennel
c'est à dire un vote à scrutin public
qui a été demandée tout au long de
l'après-midi et de la soirée par le
groupe majoritaire ici nous ne
souhaitons pas que la réalité et à
sincérité de ce vote soit contestée en
conséquence nous allons être très
attentif à ce qui va se passer dans les
seconds à venir
et si la majorité du sénat le
gouvernement
s'entêter à vouloir imposer au sénat une
conduite contraire à son propre
règlement nous en tirerions des
conséquences et nous quitterions
l'hémicycle monsieur fisher monsieur le
président fischer wipo maison mais là
c'est pas deux fois président parce que
non seulement vous voulez transgresser
un votre officielle et messi parce que
là vous interprétez et vous en tant que
président de la commission des lois
président l'article l'amendement qui a
été votée supprime l'article alors
l'article est supprimé on n'a pas à y
revenir dessus
excusez moi excusez moi de parler de
cette façon ce n'est pas dans mon
habitude mais je crois que la réalité
est celle-ci la réalité celle ci donc
nous aussi madame la présidente
s'il y avait continuité des travaux
alors que cet amendement qui est le
nôtre a été votée eh bien nous quitte
aurions aussi la séance et ce charcutage
eh bien on vous en laissera la
responsabilité
oui monsieur le président présidente
moi je n'ai pas d'abus effectivement il
peut y avoir d'autres sur
l'interprétation qui est donnée la seule
instance qui peut donner la bonne
interprétation c'est le sénat et donc on
procède au vote c'est tout bon bah oui
non mais attendez non mais vous avez pas
non non mais au nom de quoi au nom de
quoi enfin moi je dis que le
gouvernement a demandé monsieur masson
vous a pas donné la parole et non mais
madame là payante compte tenu du
contexte de ce vote est vrai qu
effectivement il pourrait très bien y
avoir un article additionnel que je
présente maintenant 10 ans ne s'est pas
terminée donc moi je pense qu
objectivement objectivement on peut de
penser d une deuxième délibération mais
non mais non
or
et le seul l'instance qui peut trancher
c'est le sénat eh ben on lui demande de
trancher
je sais plus quoi faire
chaque instant au su de tous ces débats
l'amazone
oui
monsieur le ministre si nous procédons à
un vote maintenant il faut que vous
preniez bien la mesure de la
contestation de fond qui est formulée
sur le recours à cette procédure
là où je suis je préférerais que nous
trouvions une issue plus consensuel
parce que parce que je pense que ça
n'est pas bon pour notre assemblée
il n'y a pas de solution sur l'erreur
matérielle
je pense qu'il faut réfléchir aux
répercussions qu'aurait le renvoi pur et
simple à l'assemblée nationale qui
respecterait le vote du sénat le sénat
prend la responsabilité de son vote
oui mais la demande de gouvernements et
de droit demande de vote du gouvernement
est de droit conformément à l'article
que j'ai cités au duc
alors le président bayle demande une
suspension de séance de combien de temps
mais c'est le président me dit madame la
présidente pour permettre au
gouvernement de bien réfléchir
dix minutes
il ya mes chers collègues compte tenu de
la confusion de la situation je vais
suspendre la séance jusqu'à est-ce que
vous acceptez que ce soit jusqu'à 22h30
une heure et demie suffit alors non non
pas non non non monsieur le président
longue et non je suspends au minimum
jusqu'à 22h30 ce qui permettra à tout le
monde de retrouver un peu de sérénité
voilà scénario suivant vous le verrez au
retour
non alors j'ai dit 22h30 on s'en tient
22h30
la séance est reprise
mes chers collègues j'espère où
j'espérais que cette pause aurait ramené
la sérénité dans notre assemblée dont la
sagesse est légendaire pour ma part j'ai
beaucoup réfléchi depuis que nous nous
sommes séparés jeu j'ai constaté que des
interprétations multiples était donné à
la situation assez particulière que nous
vivons ce soir dans notre assemblée la
présidence à sa responsabilité c'est une
des clés de notre fonctionnement et donc
je prends ma responsabilité je considère
que le vote qui a eu lieu de
l'amendement de suppression
tout à l'heure avant avant la suspension
à la demande d'ailleurs de scrutin
public du groupe ump
l'adoption de cet amendement de
suppression a de fait abouti au rejet de
l'ensemble du texte et en conséquence
en conséquence je lève la séance
mes chers collègues mes chers collègues
l'a dit la dignité de notre assemblée
mériterait un meilleur traitement
je les dis je prends ma responsabilité
je rappelle que ce texte va poursuivre
sa vie et qu'il n'y a aucune raison de
faire un drame de cette situation
je le répète la séance est levée
elle aurait le mandat monsieur ministre
madame je voudrais simplement donné
l'aig mes chers collègues je ne perdrai
pas mon calme la séance est levée
j'aurais dû signaler que l'ordre du jour
reprendra demain à 9h30 pour les
questions orales et à 14h30 et le soir
projet de loi organisant la concomitance
des renouvellements on en meurt faux et
conseils généraux et des conseils
régionaux
enfin
vous venez de suivre la séance au cours
de laquelle les sénateurs ont donc
rejeté ce projet de loi sur le
redécoupage électoral ce matin le
gouvernement a donc fait une demande de
seconde délibération sur l'amendement
communiste cette demande sera examinée
cet après midi à 14h30 en conférence des
présidents
si cette seconde délibération est actée
elle pourrait intervenir dès jeudi matin
en séance publique
merci de votre fidélité très bonne
journée à tous sur public sénat la
grande difficulté pour vacciner
personnes en une semaine c'est de faire
en sorte que des bonnes personnes soit
au bon endroit au bon moment avec le
matériel en bonne condition fini
l'humanitaire idéaliste de la première
époque
en 40 ans les ong se sont
professionnalisés à l'institut bioforce
dans la banlieue lyonnaise
les élèves apprennent la gestion de
projet la réparation des 4,4 et les
premiers gestes en cas d' attaque
profession humanitaire un documentaire
d'alexandre bon diffusé sur public sénat
samedi à 22 heures
pourquoi le crime organisé se féministe
il de plus en plus gros plan dans ses
paroles du monde sur ces femmes qui
prennent le pouvoir au sein de la mafia
parlement hebdo revient chaque week-end
sur les événements politiques qui ont
marqué la semaine avec un coup de
projecteur sur les grands débats au
coeur de l'assemblée nationale et du
sénat
à nos côtés pour commander c'est encore
un parlementaires députés ou sénateurs
il nous aidera à décrypter une actualité
toujours très riche et varié chaque
semaine donc emmanuel parlement hebdo
c'est le rendez vous avec l'essentiel de
la politique parlement hebdo c'est
samedi à 14 heures la rupture elle
connaît alors qu'elle présidait le plus
important cabinet d'avocats au monde à
chicago christine lagarde délaisse cette
brillante carrière pour repartir à zéro
elle entre en politique en 2005 d'abord
moderato comme ministre du commerce
extérieur puis allegro comme le ministre
de l'économie de l'industrie et de
l'emploi avant que d'affronter
fortissimo la pire crise économique de
l'après-guerre une gestion au côté de
nicolas sarkozy salué par tous alors la
reprise est-elle à notre portée l'emploi
date il se stabilise et le business vert
va t'il nous sauver ce ne sont pas les
questions qui vont manquer christine
lagarde dans leader
bonjour aujourd'hui nous sommes dans le
bon endroit au palais de tokyo pour
parler du sucre parce que nous sommes au
little palais qui le coin des enfants
pour est-ce que vous avez choisi ce
sujet aujourd'hui
bien sûr que c'est important de
comprendre la globalisation de
comprendre notre société de comprendre
l'avenir à partir de deux choses
concrètes et rien n'est plus concrète le
sucre vers du concret que ce qu'on mange
et en même temps vous allez voir que
c'est un sujet qui renvoie les choses
incroyablement profonde complexe et
qu'il y beaucoup de chaussures sur sur
l'humanité d'abord avant de parler de
son avenir
d'où vient le sucre c'est un aliment qui
remonte à quand les hommes ont toujours
voulu adoucir ce qu'ils mangeaient et
pendant très très longtemps partout à
travers le monde
j'entends très longtemps c'est à dire
jusque puisque le début de deux de l'ère
moderne
c'était le miel qui représentait la
forme de la douceur on va mais elle
était très rudimentaire et puis à peu
près au tournant de notre temps est
apparu dans le pacifique puis en inde
produits qu'on appelait le sucre c'est à
dire quelque chose qui se faisait
apprendra à partir de quelque chose qui
ressemble la canne à sucre qui était et
qui avait rien à voir avec le sucre
moderne mais qui était une sorte de
soupe lui qui a dit
d'où 6 et les produits très très très
luxueux comme du très rare est cher
surtout que moment où il a été inventé
au troisième siècle de notre ère en inde
la cristallisation tu as la possibilité
de sortir véritablement les cristaux de
sucre saccharose du de la bagasse
c'est-à-dire de de la cire ou de canne à
sucre
c'était un produit qui incroyablement
luxeuil saqqara d'ailleurs le mot vient
du sanskrit il est ensuite passé en
europe est en réalité le mouvement du
sucre c'est pacifique inde pays arabes
les l'islam la mène en espagne et c'est
les slams l'espagne qui la mène ensuite
xvème siècle en amérique latine pendant
toute cette période du 2e siècle au
xviiie siècle
le sucre est associé à deux idées
contradictoires mais simultanées
la première il faut les esclaves pour le
produire l'histoire du succès une
histoire mais ce lavage par tous les
esclavages africain le lavage indien le
scav âge on avait une platine le lavage
afrique et la deuxième idée c'est que le
supplée d'incroyablement luxueuse de
produits qui réservait louis xiv par
exemple avait un sucrier avec une clé et
c'est grande cérémonie louve avec la clé
une pincette ce et ceux qui le donnait
les considérer comme les extrêmes
privilégier le sud commence à se
développer un peu quand quand l'
esclavage se développent et permet le
développement du sucre en amérique
latine avec les esclaves et quand
la demande de suivre augmenté avec
l'apparition du café du chocolat qu
absolument un mangeable imbuvable sens
sans sucre donc là il ya une demande
croissante de sucre et le sucre
comme tous les produits de luxe se
démocratise on est à la fin à la fin du
xviiie siècle contrairement aux autres
aliments dont il nous est arrivé de
paris le sucre n'a jamais taire
médicaments non c'est d'ailleurs à juste
titre puisque le sucre est un produit
extrêmement nocif
on a cru longtemps que c'était un
instrument de d'énergie mais c'est vrai
que sa pente l'énergie mais d'énergie
extrêmement rapide qui se stockent très
vite dans les muscles et dans le foie
mais qui disparaît très vite pour
devenir la grèce furent donc c'est une
illusion qu on pensait que le sucre
apporte de l'énergie on l'a cru
incertain il continue aujourd'hui dans
certaines boissons sucrées à à imaginer
que le sucre apporte de l'énergie en
fait c'est une illusion totale donc
alors qu'ils sont et pays aujourd'hui
les principaux pays producteurs de sucre
alors il faut distinguer clairement les
pays producteurs et les pays
consommateurs parce qu'il ya des
changements considérables qui sont en
cours la consommation de sucre se
développe à partir du xviiie petit à fin
du 18e 19e mais surtout à partir de 1950
où là il ya une explosion de la
production de la consommation de sucre
aujourd'hui en prison vers 1970 à peu
près dans les pays très consommateurs
qui sont d'abord l'europe et les états
unis et puis l'inde qui sont en ce
moment là déjà les trois pays les plus
consommateurs avec la russie qui est
aussi est-ce qu'on a parmi les grands
pays consommateurs on consomme jusqu'à
50 60 kg de sucre par habitant sachant
que le sucre
encore une fois bien par la pâtisserie
vient par s'est pas seulement le sucre
blanc qu'on met dans un café c'est
surtout les imaginations incroyable des
quatre ans il transforme donc on
consomme on en consomme à ce moment-là
50 60 kg dessus dans certains pays dans
d'autres dans la plupart du mono 0 en
afrique 0 je parle des années 70 0 en en
chine 0 et a très peu et puis la
production alors est pour l'essentiel à
partir du 19ème jusqu'au 19ème siècle la
canne à sucre points à partir du blocus
l'angleterre de la france qu'on a
développé le sucre de betterave qui
avait été inventé avant mais qu'on a
développée à ce moment là et pendant
très longtemps jusqu'à 1960 à peu près
on produit autant de sucre de canne que
le sucre de betterave et puis a pâti de
la santé oms et 1070 on s'est mis un
problème beaucoup plus de canne à sucre
que de que 2 mettra donc pour ce qui est
de la production est là elle a explosé
puisqu'on est passé de 30 millions de
tonnes mondiaux vers 1950 à 150 millions
d'années mondiaux aujourd'hui avec très
peu d'exportations le sucre matières
brutes ne se ne voyage pas le sucre
cristallisé lui voyage donc il ya très
peu d'exportations et les grands pays
producteurs ont été très longtemps
producteurs et consommateurs même tomsk
vous vers un peu donc c'est l'inde
ça a été très longtemps la russie qu'il
est beaucoup moins c'est cuba qui est
simplement le pays le plus grand
producteur et consommateur à la fois et
c'est surtout le pays qui est resté le
coeur de l'industrie du sucre mondial
c'est le président brésil à cause de l'
esclavage qui a développé une industrie
très forte du sucre mais qui reste est
aujourd'hui un pays qui consomme
énormément dessus qu'on est encore
autour de 45 50 kg par habitant et qui
est le premier producteur mondial le sud
puisqu'il produit à peu près parce que
30% de la production mondiale de sucre
aujourd'hui avec une mutation très
importante donc le brésil le premier
l'inde le second l'europe
le troisième l'europe qui produit
beaucoup plus de sucre que ce que le con
surtout avec ce 7e place étonnante de la
france dans l'industrie sucrière la
france européenne avec la france qui
occupe la première place en 1ère place à
cause de l'histoire
quand j'ai fait comme à développer la
canne à sucre que la betterave 2
à cause d'eux du blocus anglais et aux
faits au fait que les prix du sucre sont
allemands subventionné compris beaucoup
plus de sucre que ce qu'on consomme et
que la france comme l'ensemble des pays
européens exporte avec la france qu'on
export mais ce que vous pouvez me dit
c'est que les pays producteurs sont
aussi les pays consommateurs
oui alors vous m'expliquez qu'il fallait
bien scindé les pays producteurs et les
pays consommateurs des sujets sont
différents pour l'avenir et pour le
présent pour le présent on est en
situation où les grands pays producteurs
sont donc le brésil pour l'essentiel et
l'inde qui consomment pour eux-mêmes et
le président qui exporte un pays qui
exporte beaucoup aussi c'est la
thaïlande qui exportent beaucoup comme
l'abus pour le riz et la russie aussi
dit qu'ils exportent nez il faut voir
qu'il ya l'émergence dans la production
d'un usage complètement différente du
sucre de canne qui est en train
d'apparaître c'est que la canne à sucre
devient et il va être sans doute pour
beaucoup dans l'avenir 1
car blanc ouazine par exemple les
aujourd'hui le bioéthanol et consomment
la moitié de la production de canne à
sucre du pays
donc le sucre n'est plus seulement un
aliment c'est aussi de naissance pour
les voitures on dit que c'est le nouvel
or vert
oui avec des avantages considérables ces
produits de l'essence hors pétrole c'est
la canne à sucre elle-même dégage du gaz
carbone de de l'oxygène et absorbe du
gaz carbonique donc ça ça permet la
réduction des gaz à effet de serre c'est
un effet psychologique très important
mais alors est ce que ce sont les mêmes
qui vont qui transforment le sucre en
bioéthanol et qui aujourd'hui gère
l'industrie sucrière
ce sont deux métiers différents oui sont
deux métiers différents mais ça a été
même parce que l'industrie sucrière va
se déplacer vers sec
et puis aussi il faut voir que comme
l'inde comme le sucre quelque chose qui
se déplace très difficilement
la production va se localiser là où
aller voilà on en consomme
or il ya un effondrement de la
consommation dans les pays développés on
est passé de 60 kg par habitant à
certains pays vin par habitant la france
est passée de 40 à 20 kg par habitant
mot clé c'est un effondrement remplacé
par la saccharine et par tous les les
substituts
certains pays restent des gros
consommateurs le plus gros consommateur
c'est cuba c'est la jamaïque c'est
l'inde c'est l'australie mais les mêmes
les états unis commencent à baisser
puisque le sucré on chasse en sucre etc
et fait le sucre ou tu pratiquement
autant de monde que le tabac tue
pratiquement autonome que le tabac tous
les ans autour de trois millions et demi
de personnes
on est dans un véritable défi sanitaire
oui c'est un vieux con facteur d'obésité
considérable longue
il ya d'une part n'est fondremand de la
consommation de sucre dans les pays
développés mais comme la population du
monde se développe a lieu et une
augmentation considérable quand même
donc la consommation
la production sucrière la demande
sucrière aujourd'hui est passé à 160
millions de tonnes et la production ne
suffit pas puisque la production très
inférieurs à sa position et à 140 donc à
une vraie surtout si on veut faire
évoluer son utilisation verrou parce
qu'on parle de lait bio éthanol mais
aussi l'électricité qu'il est possible
de lui or une fois un des facteurs très
importants on sait que les pays comme
beaucoup de pays africains qui ne
consomment pas du taux de sucre ont
passé par la consommation que vous avez
des pays qui sont un kilo de sucre par
habitat encore aujourd'hui donc il y
aura plus de sucre consommé en chine
plus je suis monsieur consommer en elle
s'est attirée par an et par habitant
donc évidemment ça va ce début toute
l'afrique est cédé à ce niveau là d'où
l'afrique qui aurait pu s'il y avait eu
une économie sucrière en afrique
développer une production de la canne à
sucre peut se cultiver ou sur l'afrique
va certainement devenir un grand pays
sucré bien qu'il ait par rapport à
convaincre pour donner un américain par
exemple autour entre sas a atteint 66
est en train de descendre à 35
maintenant et la france et des san
autour de l'objectif c'est d'aller à 20
kg par habitant pour les pays développés
et donc ce qui fait que la consommation
va monter en moyenne mondiale
et ceci va entraîner des conséquences
assez radical c'est que progressivement
ailleurs à la fois une très forte
augmentation et le sucre est
certainement dans le système financier
mondial une des valeurs les plus sûres
aussant sont évidemment la demande va
augmenter
évidemment la production est
insuffisante donc il ya des bulles
sucrière il ya des spéculations sur le
sud par exemple cette année
tout dépend de ce qui va se passer en
inde si l'inde est capable de produire
autant de cibles que nécessaire pour ce
pays qui est devenu premier consommateur
mondial de sucre les prix vont
stabiliser
si la récolte n'est pas bonne le prix de
chimie explosé et il y aura une une
rationnement par les prix et donc ses
manières chiffres toutes les autres
matières premières peine à retrouver une
hausse durable et le sucre lui affiche
une santé insolente à cause du fait qu'
on ne la produit beaucoup moins de sucre
que la demande la demande de sucre
mondiale 3% par an crise ou pas crise
elles augmentent de 3% par an et l'offre
elle-même de cointe par le haut si les
taux qu'il y a il va y avoir une
augmentation des prix du sucre et une
certaine pays
le sucre l'industrie du sud permettra de
redynamiser leur économie je pense que
l'industrie du sucre et sera essentiel
au brésil parce que c'est un pays qui en
fabrique de façon utile et pour
l'éthanol je pense que le jour où je
pense que l'inde va devoir bouleverser
son régime de production du sucre
parce que l'un ne produit pas assez de
sucre et la consommation su qu on n va
augmenter il ya des besoins importants
c'est à déraper ou celle encore
totalement réglementée ça m'a changé
l'hallali maurice à la réunion l'île
maurice l'un des très grands fac
producteurs aujourd'hui un producteur et
un exportateur très important le sucre
les premiers exportateurs mondiaux la
réunion a aussi utilisé le sucre autre
nom et la réunion est très intéressante
parce que à la réunion une maison sur
six à son électricité produite par du
sucre
donc c'est un exemple très intéressant
d'un usage du de la canne à sucre pour
produire de l'énergie non seulement pour
la version wii pour l'électricité on
peut penser que ça pourrait développer
je pense que la canne à sucre deviendra
aussi un facteur très important de
l'économie africaine
là tout est à faire merci jacques attali
et la semaine prochaine on se retrouve
pour une autre conversation à venir je
vous invite à retrouver cette émission
sur notre site internet publicsenat.fr
rubrique conversation à venir vous
pouvez réagir vous écrire consulter nos
archives ou encore podcasts et nos
émissions
merci al assad prochain
le docu débat cette semaine c'est une
émission qui va certainement créer la
controverse puisque nous allons parler
de l'exploitation de l'uranium par areva
au gabon et au niger
y at il oui ou non contamination
radioactive
hors norme des terres de long et donc de
la population pourquoi tant de mineurs
sont ils morts ces dernières années
le docu le débat c'est sur public sénat
je vous retrouve avec plaisir chaque
jour du lundi au jeudi à 18h sur public
sénat pour une tranche d'information
complète politique et parlementaire avec
des invités des chroniqueurs des
reportages le décryptage politique c'est
tous les jours sur public sénat décembre
1989 un mois de la chute du mur de
berlin c'est au tour de la roumanie de
faire la une des médias du monde entier
si nous interrompons nos programmes
c'est que la situation devient chaque
minute chaque peur plus tendues plus
grave en roumanie
d'abord avec le coup charnier de
timisoara puis l'exécution du couple
ceausescu
comment les télévisions françaises sont
elles traitées cdd
qui a manipulé qui la roumanie dans
l'oeil des médias
un documentaire d'antonio wagner sur
public sénat lundi à 18h30 et 22h30
le mardi public sénat vous propose des
soirées décryptage avec conversation
d'avenir jacques attali et stéphanie
bonvicini vous font partager leurs
réflexions sur les avenirs possibles et
hélène risser des habits les super
communicants
que sont devenus les hommes politiques à
travers leurs discours présent et passé
grâce à l'ina les mardis décryptage
c'est sur public sénat à 18h30 et 22h30
c'est l'article 39 de la constitution
l'initiative de la loi appartient au
premier ministre mais aussi aux membres
du parlement
quand l'initiative de la loi vient du
gouvernement c'est un projet de loi
quand l'initiative de la loi bien des
parlementaires cela s'appelle une
proposition de loi ce qui veut dire que
les sénateurs comme les députés peuvent
rédiger des propositions de loi ces
textes s'ils sont adoptés deviendront
des lois
pour déposer une proposition de loi
c'est facile il faut d'abord la rédiger
et c'est peut-être là où c'est le plus
difficile car il faut savoir ce que l'on
veut dire et le dire en termes
juridiques
une fois que les textes est prêt il est
saisi sur un ordinateur
le sénateur ou le député le signe et le
dépose au service de la séance de
l'assemblée concernée d'un point de vue
strictement juridique la proposition de
loi peut émaner d'un seul parlementaire
mais du point de vue politique si l'on
veut que sa proposition est une chance
d'être discutée et d'aboutir
il faut mieux que ce soit une
proposition collective de nombreuses
propositions de loi sont déposées chaque
année par les sénateurs en moyenne 100
par an mais seuls 20% des lois en
application aujourd'hui sont issus de
proposition de loi pourtant certaines
propositions de loi ont profondément
marqué la vie parlementaire la
proposition de loi organique qui est
devenue la loi de 2001 sur les lois de
finances qui encadre la discussion
budgétaire et qui est une initiative
conjointe du rapporteur général du
budget du sénat et du rapporteur général
du budget à l'assemblée nationale
c'est un excellent exemple dans un
domaine très sensible la procédure
budgétaire c'est probablement la
proposition la plus emblématique que
l'on a vu aboutir depuis dix ou quinze
ans pour être examinés il faut que les
propositions de loi sur jugée recevable
par le bureau du sénat
il faut ensuite qu'elle soit inscrite à
l'ordre du jour c'est en quelque sorte
l'agenda du sénat
la révision constitutionnelle de juillet
2008 permet d'ailleurs un partage de cet
ordre du jour entre le gouvernement et
le parlement ce qui devrait permettre un
meilleur examen des propositions de loi
la révision des limites ouvre ce qu'on
pourrait appeler une fenêtre c'est à
dire permet effectivement aux
parlementaires de jouer un rôle
quantitativement plus important tout
simplement parce que l'ordre du jour
n'est plus aussi tenu aussi verrouillé
est-ce que ça renforce l'initiative
parlementaire d'abord ça suppose que les
parlementaires fassent usage première
chose deuxième chose il n'est pas exclu
que les parlementaires souhaitent que y
compris pendant leur semaine soit
inscrit à l'ordre du jour des projets de
loi dont des textes d'initiative
gouvernementale donc là je dirais qu'il
ya un jeu politique entre gouvernements
et parlements en fonction aussi des
urgences et les préoccupations du moment
la révision constitutionnelle ne permet
donc qu'en théorie un meilleur examen
des propositions de loi car en pratique
l'ordre du jour a déjà été bousculé et
les sénateurs ont parfois dû renoncer à
leur semaine réservée pour examiner en
priorité des projets de loi du
gouvernement au détriment de leur
proposition de loi
entièrement dévouée dédié consacré au
neuvième art ça discute la bande
dessinée des enfants je vis avec mes
personnes moi je les dessine de terrain
lui arrive des choses incroyables ces
wonder woman c'était une envie depuis
longtemps de faire une sorte de super
héroïne coureurs à pied le fait quelques
foulées
le tennisman envoie quelques balles puis
ça et passionnant bah moi je rôde mon
cerveau donc je bouquine ce que j'ai été
la veille un micro merci c'est gentil un
bad et ça travaille ici hein je suis sur
les dernières pages c'est un peu le
intéressante au niveau des croquis j'ai
ici est en préparation
lorsque je m'amuse car chez ça c'est pas
des choses qu'on a l'habitude de voir
tous les jours c'est vraiment un
découpage complètement ceci mais très
graphique un vrai régal pour ceux qui
aiment la bande dessinée
parlement hebdo revient chaque week-end
sur les événements politiques qui ont
marqué la semaine avec un coup de
projecteur sur les grands débats au
coeur de l'assemblée nationale et du
sénat
à nos côtés pour commander c'est encore
un parlementaires députés ou sénateurs
il nous aidera à décrypter une actualité
toujours très riche et varié chaque
semaine donc emmanuel parlement hebdo
c'est le rendez vous avec l'essentiel de
la politique parlement hebdo c'est
samedi à 14 heures
la grande difficulté pour un vacciner
personnes en une semaine c'est de faire
en sorte que les bonnes personnes soit
au bon endroit au bon moment avec le
matériel en bonne condition fini
l'humanitaire idéaliste de la première
époque
en 40 ans les ong se sont
professionnalisés à l'institut bioforce
dans la banlieue lyonnaise
les élèves apprennent la gestion de
projet la réparation des cats iv et les
premiers gestes en cas d' attaque
profession humanitaire à documentaire
d'alexandre bombe diffusé sur public
sénat samedi à 22 heures